what is going on everybody welcome to a
django tutorial series django is a web
framework for python all the framework
is is just a foundation a set of tools
for you to build on top of in this case
to make a website well the first
questions that people are going to ask
when they start looking into web
development with python they're going to
find that there's like 20 frameworks for
python which one do I choose for the
most part you've got high level and low
level frameworks Django is the highest
level framework and the rest are pretty
low level frameworks so would compare
Django to something like flask okay so
we've got a flask tutorial series on
Python programming net as well and the
main difference between these two is
with with flask flask allows you a lot
of freedom to create things your way to
do them in a custom manner exactly
however you want
Django on the other hand forces you to
do things the Django way the trade-off
here is under flask you can do things
your way but your way is almost
certainly not the best way and with
Django the Django way is almost
certainly the best way and if you make
an entire website are always doing the
Django way overall you're going to have
one out most likely because honestly if
you're being honest with yourself you
are bad at creating systems even the
extremely talented girls and guys at
Django couldn't get it right the first
time it's taken thousands of web
developers and just developers in
general and millions of end users using
the Django framework to get it where it
is today and it's act it's still under
active development very active
development so using something like
Django is very tested it's going to
scale it's going to be secure and it's
going to be efficient and and by scale I
really mean two things one you know a
website scaling that's really that's a
lot that has to do with some some
back-end things a little bit more but by
scale I usually mean you know most
people they refer to scale as and how
many users can it hold like can it can
it go from having 5,000 users to 5
million users but actually when a
project scales in my mind it's it's when
the actual
project itself scales where you add a
bunch of new things and features and
stuff like that what ends up happening
is this I like to show this picture it's
one of my favorite pictures it's you
know you start with a clean slate you
build this beautiful house
and everything's working out really well
maybe add a porch to and it's cool then
you start adding other little things and
before you know it you've made a huge
mess okay so with Django it starts you
out right out of the gate with something
like this where you've got your main
website in your project and you start to
build out into what are called apps the
premise with Django is that every
website is really just a combination of
certain apps so in this case you might
have some apps one might be a forum
another one might be a blog and another
one might be a store ok and these are
all contained on the same website so the
terminology can get really confusing
really fast especially with something
like Django which is very high-level
very abstracted and it can get just be
too much sometimes and a little bit
overwhelming so I wouldn't confuse I
want to focus too much on the
terminology but basically you know you
might hear that a web app a lot of times
people consider a web app to be a web
page or a let's say phone app to be like
the whole thing not to have sub apps
right but with Django basically your
whole website has these little sub apps
basically in each app actually could be
a standalone website right you might
have just a store you might have just a
blog or it might just be a forum or
something like that as time goes on
we'll build out this kind of diagram so
you can better see what's going on but
at the basic level that's what it is so
so the beauty of using Django is that it
can grow in a way that requires
foresight that you probably just don't
have when you're initially setting out
for a project but with Django they
basically give you that foresight using
the certain paradigm that they're kind
of forcing on you but it's probably a
good choice so enough of that let's go
ahead and get Django this is super
challenging not really all you have to
do is just do pip install Django one
thing to note is I'm on a Windows
operating system it doesn't matter what
operating system you're using here so
the all of the code I love Django the
back end the development server
everything will be the same no matter
what your operating system is Django is
blind to the operating system basically
just doesn't care so everything's the
same no matter what your operating
system is use whatever you want
same goes for the editor use whatever
editor you want I don't care
PIPP installed Django for this tutorial
I'm using Django 1.9 if you do pip
install Django you'll get the latest
version whatever that happens to be I
just recommend you do that but if for
whatever reason you want to make sure
you're using the same version as me you
can do with double equals there and say
the version basically 1.9 once you've
done that you have Django and you're
ready to rumble so we'll move this over
obviously have to hit enter here but I
already have it so we'll move that over
this is the Django website you can come
here you can if you're having some
problems installing it you can come to
download and read some more information
there pip install really should work one
more thing to note is I'm going to be
using Python 3 so like let's say you're
on Linux use pip install that's probably
going to install for Python 2.7 we're
going to use 3 so pip 3 if you don't
have pip 3 app get pip 3 ok so let's
move this over if you're on Windows
don't worry about pip 3 and all that
moving this over now we're going to do
is create our like project directory so
I'm just going to make a new one so I'm
right-clicking here new folder and I'm
just going to call this Django tutorials
just make sure you don't just call this
directory django or some other
conflicting path name call it something
very specific so it doesn't conflict
with another Python package now I'm
going to open up my terminal here and
windows you can hold shift right click
and open a command window there I'm not
really sure if you can do something
similar on other operating systems so
keep that in mind now once you're there
what we're going to do is django - admin
start project and you can call your
project whatever you want generally the
standard people use is my site so i'll
hit enter on my site and boom the
project is created we can go ahead and
open this up bring this down and here it
is so if we look in here we'll see
that my site just contains another
directory called my site this is just a
container it really doesn't matter what
you call this you can call it whatever
you want this needs to stay the same
because it's in your settings now so
we've got my site this is going to be
the main kind of hub of your website so
this my site directory is the equivalent
of that website project in black text
there that's your my site directory so
over here we've got to manage that pi we
can bring that up and you'll see that
it's just some simple stuff here this is
basically your command line tool where
we'll be using managed up PI quite a bit
you won't actually be reading managed up
pi very often but that's what it looks
like anyway within your my site
directory you've got init settings URLs
and WSGI in it just tells python this is
to be treated like a package if you've
watched my flash tutorial series we
actually put the entire website in the
init dot PI file that's not going to fly
with django is not going to put up with
that junk you're going to have to do
things the right way
the django way here so so that you'll
just leave that blank you won't even
touch that this is settings' this is the
settings for your website again this is
the main hub well we'll talk more and
probably hit up the settings file a lot
more as we get into more advanced
installed apps is probably the most
important thing well it's not the most
important thing but it's one of the most
important things that you'll have to
remember every time you add an
application you have to manually add it
here so if you download like like what
django lends itself for people to use
and share each other's applications if
you download someone else's application
you have to add it in here you have to
install it I'll show you guys how to do
that it's really simple probably the
most important thing here is actually
this line this is a secret key
hence secret keep it secret don't share
it if you put your website up on github
something like that do not put this here
this was used for encryption basically
where things like your session stuff
like that if someone has access this key
they can decrypt decrypt the session
claim themselves as an admin Rhian crypt
and they will be treated like an admin
on your website so don't do that so
otherwise this other stuff will kind of
get to each little part of this as we go
on but for the most part
as you're getting started the main thing
is going to be right here so closing out
of this we're pretty much done with
settings now URLs this is the main kind
of controller of your website right now
we just have one URL pattern the URL
patterns are regular expressions if
you're not familiar egular expressions I
highly suggest you at least get somewhat
familiar but at least to start you don't
need to know very much carrot this
carrot just means the beginning of a
string and the other one that you'll see
fairly often is a dollar sign that's the
end of a string everything else remains
the same so basically this URL pattern
just basically says and all these URL
patterns start after the initial domain
name okay if that all sounds like
gibberish to you don't worry there's a
lots of swallow with Django and just
take it very slow and ask questions
right so if you have any questions along
the way just ask them under the video
you can go to the Python programming
netcommunity ask them there whatever you
can go Stack Overflow reddit all this
stuff ask questions I'll at least answer
whatever I can anyway this is that file
I'm not really sure why it's telling me
I've modified something I don't think
I've modified anything so I couldn't
close it anyway that's your URLs
basically this file will just point to
your apps okay so this file is
underneath that main website project and
it points to the various apps and as
time goes on you'll see that the apps
themselves have their own URL spy files
so I can get kind of confusing but at
least that was very confusing to me you
are probably much smarter than I was so
anyway back up to our command line
terminal whatever we're now going to
interact with that manage a high file
we're currently in Django - tutorials so
we need to change directory to my site
so CD my site and now I can interact
with manage mine
now I have many versions of Python
installed on my machine so I have to
explicitly say which version of Python I
want to use even the subversion so for
you if you're on like Mac or Linux you
could probably say Python 3 okay that's
not going to work with me I can say
Python but that corresponds Python 2.7
so I don't want that either so I'm going
to explicitly say Python where it is
chances are if you just have one version
of Python installed on your machine you
can either just do Python or if you're
on like Linux Python 3 ok but I give the
full path C colon slash - 35 pythons
that's the full path to Python for me
then we say manage PI and for now we are
going to do it's called run server go
ahead and do that hit enter and you may
see this what you absolutely will see
you have unapplied migrations okay don't
worry about that migrations basically
every time you add new models I suppose
you will need to do make migrations and
migrate we will talk about that later
feel free to run it you will notice that
it actually tells you exactly what you
need to do to fix this little error it
says run Python managed up I migrated to
apply them so the errors and stuff that
you're going to see here are super
helpful errors so go ahead over to your
browser and go to the following URL it's
this one 27001 colon 8000 basically one
27001 is just localhost so that's your
local IP so this is obviously not
accessible outside of your home network
and actually well if you put the
computer's local IP as far as I know the
local IP will correspond but don't worry
about that anyway one 27001 colon 8000
basis is on port 8000 so this is your
development server so django comes
shipped with this awesome development
server basically over here you're
running the server and you can see all
the requests so you can actually see
here we made a request to to hear the
responses at 200 which is successful and
then we did not get a fav icon so that
was returning a 404 for us I don't worry
about that you may or may not be even
seeing that I'm not really sure why I'm
seeing that 404 be quite honest anyway
shouldn't have one but maybe there's
like a cache or something anyway so you
should see a page that looks like this
if you don't see a page that looks like
this something went wrong
you should have an error here and read
the error see what it says they are very
useful errors otherwise it should look
just like this if you have any problems
feel free
post them below once you get to this
point you're ready to move on to the
next tutorial next tutorial will
actually start working on making
something useful show up here rather
than you know kind of default message so
anyways
stay tuned the next tutorial questions
cost below otherwise as always thanks
for watching